professor levin
what puzzle do you find most important
what do you think about on a semi daily
basis or even perhaps multiple times a
day and then we'll go around the table
here with chris fields and carl fursten
next and then it's essentially me taking
a backseat and allowing you all to free
flow just for the audience to know i
know you all know this template already
yeah um so so the thing i think about uh
many times a day uh has to do with the
scaling of cognition so i want to
understand two two major things one is
how it is that uh some collection of uh
competent uh parts comes together to
form a an emergent self with uh
preferences goals memories um cognitive
capacities that belong to it but not to
the individual parts so i want to
understand how that how that emerges how
the goals of uh you know sort of humble
um
a simple uh simple kinds of systems
scale up into much more grandiose goals
that we see in during during development
during behavior uh you know during uh
culture and and so on and and i'm also
very interested in uh the sort of the
left side of that spectrum where does it
begin you know is there really a zero on
the spectrum i think that uh all of us
we here would agree that there is a
spectrum for these things it's not a set
of binary categories but what happens at
the very left side of the spectrum and
so one of the first questions you know
when we get to that that um that i'd
written down to ask both chris and
carlos to sort of comment on
what does the what does the venn diagram
look like of of the set of things that
are alive versus the set of things that
are cognitive yeah how do those two
categories relate to each other um do
they overlap is one a subset of the
other and what really happens at the
very beginning you know like
can we can we develop a kind of um
which which i think i think both of them
have been working on a kind of basically
a kind of pan-psychism that doesn't
doesn't sort of paint on new
cognitive mysteries on top of physics
that works perfectly well but instead to
try and to try to view physics from the
bottom up as having already a useful
cognitive lens on it and how does that
help us to build up cognition so that's
that's something that i think about
every day is there a difference between
cognition and
consciousness is one distinct is there
overlap
is someone a subset
i i actually can't conceive of
cognition without
consciousness
which i i prefer to call awareness
not just to be perverse but because in
many cases
consciousness is
used in a way that implicitly means
self-consciousness
whereas awareness is often used in a way
that does not make that implication
and
it's i find it difficult to conceive of
cognition without any kind of awareness
at all
so so so could i just so i'll ask a
question then based on what what chris
just said and then what when you know
and what carl has to say about it so so
what do you think about the so-called
heart problem is there in fact a heart
problem at all
i would um
i would take andy clark's view on this
who has worked closely with david
chalmers um
i i i don't think so no i i i don't
think that the hard problem in and of
itself is um
is the um
interesting um focus of inquiry
i think the um the move that i see in
philosophy um has been to the meta
problem or the meta hard problem which
is um as andy clark puts it quite
succinctly is why do we spend so much
time puzzling about why we are aware um
so
just asking that question um speaks to i
think the nature of the heart problem
which is a sort of very much a second
order or meta um a metric capability
that we can
make sense of our own sense making and
we um associate that with selfhood so
one has to ask the question what kinds
of systems
again i think particles or creatures
would have the capacity to represent
selfhood and furthermore
represent
the counterfactuals
that would enable you to ask the
question why am i conscious that
immediately this logically presupposes
that there is an alternative hypothesis
another counterfactual that i'm not
conscious
so imagine now you're talking to
a creature you're talking to me that has
this capacity to imagine counterfactuals
that cannot exist
so that's a remarkable capacity to have
you know um from my point of view a sort
of internal world moral agenda model
where counterfactuals can exist is is
quite remarkable i i don't imagine that
a
thermostat or a virus or
an e coli will have a sufficiently
sophisticated set of you know
electrochemical
uh dynamics or kinetics that would
enable them to physically represent
counterfactuals of this sort and i could
go on um
the usual line of argument is why do we
have models why do we have the capacity
to represent counterfactuals um the um
you end up with saying yes you have to
have them
just if you
um
contemplate
things that plan